The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: A lot of what we
have done, until today, we
sort of assumed, at one place
or another, that the people
were unable to borrow.
For example, a lot of the
s-shaped problem that we have
seen along the way, people would
be able to escape from
them if only they
could borrow.
For example, all of the issues
on risk that we've discussed,
that people have these shocks
and they lose their business.
And that puts them back on the
left part of the curve.
This could be removed if you
were able to borrow your way
out of these problems.
So when you are in a bad
shock, you borrow.
And when you are in good state,
you reimburse, and
everything is good.
So it seems that we needed to
spend some time discussing.
We can't really take
it as given that
people can't borrow.
First, because it's not
true, actually.
Poor people borrow a lot.
It depends, a bit, from
country to country.
But in a country like India,
for example, about 70% of
people will have some loan from
someone, usually not from
a bank, but from a moneylender
or a shopkeeper or their
landlord or something
like that.
So there are actually a lot
of lending-borrowing
relationships around.
So it doesn't seem to be a very
good assumption to start
with the idea that people
can't borrow.
Secondly is, even if they
couldn't borrow, we want to
spend some time and
try to understand
why that's the case.
So in a sense, we could have
done this many lectures ago.
But finally, we are now getting
the crux of this
borrowing question.
What the newspaper article, for
today, made kind of clear
is that this is one way, one
reason why you should be
interested in these things or
you might be interested in
this things.
Microcredit is being discussed
a lot these days.
Has anyone heard what is
happening to Yunus these days?
Have any of you heard like
what's the situation?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Did you say, Yunus?
PROFESSOR: Yunus, yeah.
What's happening with Yunus?
AUDIENCE: I don't know the
details, but he's kind of
getting pushed out of the
organization that he started,
Grameen, the microfinance
banking [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so he's being
pushed out of Grameen on
sort of technical reasons.
I mean it's not.
He is older than 70.
And then the government is
arguing that Grameen is a
public bank, because
the state owns some
parts of the capital.
But a very small part,
because Grameen is
largely held by the borrowers.
They're now trying
to push him out.
And at the same time, there is
a discourse along the line
that, ooh, maybe microcredit is
not all that its cracked up
to be, et cetera.
This follows a big event in
India, in November, where, in
Andhra Pradesh, one of the hot
beds of microfinance in India,
the government decided that
it was now illegal to--
issued and ordinance saying
that it was illegal to ask
people to repay in the absence
of the local mayor.
So given that the local mayor
are not always in the field,
always present, et cetera, that
turns out to be a pretty
big constraint.
So all the repayments stopped
to microfinance agencies in
Andhra Pradesh, in November.
And to this day, they haven't
really restarted.
And in the context of that, you
have had a lot of articles
in the press about maybe
microcredit is actually bad,
maybe microcredit is
the new usury.
But I don't want to go into the
details of whether it's
good or bad now, because you're
going to do it in the
next lecture.
What I want to do is to give
us some tools, today.
So it's going to be a little bit
more theoretical lecture
than usually.
I want to give us some tools
to try to understand why it
might be difficult for the poor
to borrow, why the poor
might face higher interest
rates, and what microcredit
has done that can partially
solve this program or why it
doesn't solve them
fully, et cetera.
That's kind of where
we're heading, now.
So maybe we can start with some
facts that it's good to
have in mind.
And then we are going to have a
series of simple models that
we are going to try to
apply to these facts.
So the first fact is that most
of the poor do not have access
to any kind of formal credit,
excluding microfinance, which
reaches about 200 million
people worldwide.
So most of the poor don't borrow
from a bank or from a
credit union or something
like that.
There are some numbers that are
coming from the the data
set on the life of the
poor, under $1 a day.
You see, on the left side,
the fraction of
people who have a loan.
And you see that it's
not nothing.
Actually, the number
six is wrong.
It's more.
60% of people had a loan in
India, Cote d'Ivoire, 31%, 12%
in Indonesia, 93% in Pakistan.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is there is such
a big discrepancy between--
or why [INAUDIBLE]
informal market in Pakistan?
PROFESSOR: So first, what
you notice is that
everywhere you have.
The fact that a lot of the
loans that people.
So there are two facts in this
corner-- or three facts.
One is that it is not that
credit access is 0 in most
countries, except in Panama,
where it's pretty low.
The second fact is maybe what
you were talking about, that
there is a lot of viability,
where in a place like Pakistan
or India-- once the typo
is corrected--
you have an enormous amount of
lending, like 93% of people
have a loan.
And the third fact is that these
loans are mostly not
from the formal sector, with
the possible exception of
Indonesia, that has 25%
of loans coming
from the formal sector.
Do you want to re-ask your
question to make sure then?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean, just
Pakistan has such percentage
of individual with loans.
I mean it would be more
understandable that fraction
of loans coming from a bank in
a country that doesn't have
that much lending would be
lower, just because there
isn't that much opportunity.
What surprises me is how low the
fraction of loans that are
coming from a bank, given
how many individuals
have loans at all.
So I was wondering if there is
a reason that that's the case
in Pakistan or is
it an anomaly?
PROFESSOR: So in a sense,
we could ask the
question two ways.
Why is the informal loan market
so particularly active
in Pakistan?
Or why is the formal
market so absent?
And I think the first question,
in a sense, is the
way to ask it.
Basically, in Pakistan, there
is not much more formal
lending then in a place like,
say, Cote d'Ivoire.
But there is much more informal
lending, so there is
much more activity.
That varies a lot.
That varies from country
to country.
Within countries, it also varies
from place to place.
And it also varies even within
a village, within a region.
Who has access to credit, who
doesn't have access to credit
also varies.
So I can't really answer the
question, right now.
But I'm sort of hoping that,
by the end of the lecture,
we'll have some elements that
we can apply back to saying,
why are things different
in Pakistan ?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the percent
of people with a loan
[INAUDIBLE] in developed
countries?
PROFESSOR: What's the percentage
of people with a
loan in developed countries?
I think it would be very,
very, very high.
Because, as soon as you have a
credit card, you have a loan.
So I think, as a fraction of
adults, that it would be
pretty close to one,
I would say.
You're absolutely right.
I don't know if this is
what you had in mind.
But this is lower than in
developed countries.
And what is particularly
striking is the low access to
any kind of formal lending.
AUDIENCE: How would it look
different if it was urban
instead of rural households?
Because like Panama
is really weird.
It must be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Few people
living [INAUDIBLE].
In the same table, we also have
the urban households.
They will have more loans
and more informal loans.
So the ratio of informal to
formal in urban households is
actually not that different
from what it is here.
You have more loans and more
informal loans and more formal
loans, with a ratio--
to my knowledge--
remaining more or
less constant.
That's the first fact, a fair
amount of loans but very few
formal loans.
The second fact is more
like a history fact.
Governments have tried,
historically, to do
something about it.
So in the 1960s and the 1970s,
many governments of developing
countries, in India, in Brazil,
in Colombia, in Peru,
in Mexico tried to either force
or subsidize the banks,
either public banks or
government banks, to go and
lend to the poor.
So in India, for example, the
way it happened is, first, the
banks were nationalized, by Mrs.
Gandhi, during the same
period as The Emergency.
They were nationalized
in two waves.
And then the banks, irrespective
of whether they
were nationalized or not, were
then told that they could not
open a branch in a town if they
did not open, at the same
time, four branches in
rural areas that were
not previously served.
So as the bank tried to expand
in an urban area, where they
had a market, they had to
expand in rural areas.
And moreover, to this day, banks
were given rules about
how their portfolio needed
to be allocated.
So you have a rule called a
priority sector rule, saying
that the bank must lend 40%
of their portfolio to the
priority sector.
The priority sector is
small enterprises
in the rural sector.
And within priority sector,
they need to do at least a
fraction to the rural sector.
So both of these things are
forcing the banks to go into
the rural areas and then forcing
them to balance their
portfolio this way and capping
the interest rate up, capping
the interest rate that
they could charge.
It had the result that loans
were pushed to farmers and
things like that.
But those loans were rather a
disaster, with very, very high
default rates.
So a lot of people never
reimbursed their loans.
And eventually, they became more
like a political giveaway
rather than a credit program.
So it became sort of expensive,
inefficient way to
give people money as opposed
to a real credit program.
Let's give you one illustration
of a political
giveaway, which is a paper by
Shawn Cole, which looks at
what he calls lending cycle.
You're missing something
important, which is what is on
the x-axis, over here, is the
year until the next election.
So this is the year.
There is an election about
every five years.
So this is saying this
is the year just
before the next election.
And what you're seeing is that
the year before an election,
you get a huge boost in
lending, suddenly.
And this is for public banks.
And if we look at private
banks-- there are a few left--
you don't have these political
lending cycle.
And another thing that he has,
which is interesting, is that
you get more of this boost in
swing districts, in districts
that are where the margin of
victory in the previous
election was low, then in safe
districts, where it's pretty
clear who was going to
win the election.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I might
have missed it.
So why is there more lending
before an election?
Is that because after the person
gets elected, everyone
just defaults [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So remember all of
the facts that I just said.
You get more lending just
before the election.
It's only public banks.
And it's only in swing
districts, in districts where
the margin of victory in the
previous election was close.
So why do they lend more?
AUDIENCE: They borrow
[INAUDIBLE], because the
candidates will make a promise
that they'll [INAUDIBLE]
don't have to pay [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
The default rate is
so high that loans
are pretty much gifts.
So if you give more of it, than
it's like vote buying
kind of activities.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you
go back to the
previous slide for a second?
Why is it 0, negative
0.1, negative 0.2?
PROFESSOR: So 0 is just
a normalization.
So it starts at 0.
It is saying that any year that
is not a year just before
the election is below.
Because this is to show, in
relation to that year, the old
one is negative.
An you have the little
standard errors on
the side, as well.
Good question.
Whatever the level is,
he's normalized them.
So basically, that is telling
you that even
if you had the effort.
It's not that Grameen's
didn't try.
But in India--
and then it's also the case
in other countries--
eventually, they stopped trying
to at least use these
banks as banks.
They are more used as like
pushing money away.
Eventually, in India, they
decided to shut down the
social banking program
in the early 1990s.
Now the banks that don't have
to start in rural areas.
They still have the priority
sector rules, but they don't
have to start in rural areas.
So that's the fast fact of two
halves of a fact, very little
formal lending and rather not
very good performances in the
effort to lend to the poor.
The second fact, so people, when
they access loans, access
them mostly from the
informal sector.
And the second fact that is
important is that loans are
available in the informal
sector, but the interest rates
are very high, very high and
very variable, which is going
to be our next fact.
But just to say very high, the
sort of range where I think
you would get most of the rates
is between 40% a year to
200% a year.
That's pretty high, if you
compare very, very high
interest rates on your credit
card, in the US, is of the
order of maybe 20% a year.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So a question I had
while reading the article was,
yes, they're very high,
percentage-wise.
But if the loan amounts are so
small, like, say, if I were to
borrow $1 today, I have
to pay $2 tomorrow.
That's a huge percent increase,
but it's not that
big of an amount.
PROFESSOR: It's not that big
of an amount but from your
perspective.
It's a very good point.
And we're going to go back to
that, which is the fact that
it's not that big of an amount
is relevant for the bank, who
is giving you this money.
But for you, it just means
that whatever--
it's still, the interest
rate is very high.
So unless you have a very good
use for this money, the fact
that it's just $1, yet you have
somehow to find a way to
transform this $1 into
$2 next year.
We're going to go back
to your point.
From the point of view
of supply, it's
going to matter a lot.
You're going to see that.
It's going to turn out to be one
of the key things, which
is, because people borrow a lot,
these high interest rates
are, in a month, a relatively
small part.
But from the point of view of
the borrower, it means that,
not only they can't borrow much,
but they have to repay
this huge interest rate.
It comes to the daily rate.
Some people borrow on
the daily market.
For example, food vendors borrow
on the daily market.
A common rate on the daily
market is 5% a day.
So do you have like a guess of
what 5% a day is per year?
An order of magnitude?
Is it 5% multiplied by 365?
AUDIENCE: No.
Because it's compounded.
PROFESSOR: No, because
it compounds.
So if it's on the order of the
millions of percentage, it's a
very, very, very, very, high
interest rate, because it
compounds it really fast.
It's 1.05 to the power of 365.
It's a huge interest rate.
That's on the high range
but not uncommon.
There is one study that
I'm going to keep
returning to, today.
It's a lovely study on Pakistan,
where some guy,
called Aleem, went and talked
to various moneylenders and
collected very detailed data
on their operation.
And for Pakistan, he found that
the interest they charge
was 79%, almost.
And you could say, well,
this is because their
own money is expensive.
But they're own cost
of capital is 33%.
So their own money is expensive,
because they are
probably borrowing from the
bank or borrowing from
somewhere at some high cost.
But there's still a big wedge
between the cost of capital,
for them, and what they
charge the lender.
So that's fact two.
Keep in mind, high
interest rate.
Fact three is these interest
rates are not only high,
they're very variable, even
within the same village.
So if you go back to the Aleem
study, the mean was 79%.
The standard deviation is 38%.
Which means that the 95%
confidence interval includes a
very low number, like 2%
a year, and a very high
number, like 150%.
So it means you see, pretty
frequently, in the same
village, people borrowing at
very, very different traits.
So that is a certain other fact
we have to have in mind.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Was that huge range,
is that a reflection, then,
that lenders are really adept
at calculating, precisely,
someone's actual likelihood
of repayment or is that
favoritism?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So we'd have to understand
like how come
this can be so variable?
Is it likely that the likelihood
of repayment can
explain such a big range
or do we have to
think about other things?
And if it's where the likelihood
of repayment, can
it explain that much
difference?
AUDIENCE: Is this taking into
account the fact that if the
lender had a spell, then he
gets paid more, because he
needs more money?
PROFESSOR: No.
That's the average rate
that they charge.
These are really moneylenders,
like professional
moneylenders.
So I think what you're referring
to is, sometimes,
when people lend to each other,
say, you know, you and
I lend to each other.
Because you have had a bad time,
I lend you some money.
And then when I get better, you
lend me some money when
you get better.
When you see people doing that
informally, what you're seeing
is that people tend to pay
higher interest rate when
they're doing well and lower
when they're doing poorly.
But also, they tend to pay
higher interest rates when the
people who have lent them
money are doing poorly.
And they pay higher interest
rate when the lender is doing
poorly and lower interest rate
when the lender is doing well.
So the former could be just,
because I don't have money, I
can't reimburse.
The latter is a sign that people
sometimes use this
informal lending between each
other as a way of smoothing
consumption.
So we can remove that.
These are more like a way of
insuring, mutually insuring,
like you saw in the
last few lectures.
Where these are like
professional moneylenders that
are charging different rates.
So maybe we need to go back
to your question.
Is it the case that that can be
explained by the ability to
repay or do we need to bring
in some more things, like
favoritism, social
relationships, what have you?
So let's keep that in mind.
We now have three, very little
formal lending, high interest
rates, very variable
interest rates.
The fourth fact, one of the
dimension of variation is how
rich you are.
So the rich have larger loans,
and they pay lower rates.
So here's one fact for all of
India showing that the range
for the landless is between 28%
and 125% interest rate, so
again, this wide range with a
pretty high interest rate.
And the range for the people
who have land is
between 21% and 40%.
So its both a smaller range,
and it doesn't include the
very high value.
So the rich tend to pay-- and
is this is just one fact.
But we can accumulate
these facts.
That's kind of a representative
fact of that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: To some degree, that
variation is to be expected
[INAUDIBLE]
loan.
So therefore, if it is a smaller
loan, then, of course,
the percent interest rate
is going to be higher.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So to what extent can this be
explained by fixed costs?
That's the question we'll
ask in a minute.
I think you're exactly right.
And that goes back
to [INAUDIBLE]
point earlier, that fixed
costs will play a role.
The issue we are going to ask
is, why is it the case that,
even if there is a relatively
small fixed cost, that
translates into such large
differences in
the interest rate?
And we're going to see that.
But you're exactly right.
That's exactly the intuition
is that it has to be that
there is some fixed
costs of lending
buried here, somewhere.
So in that case, there
is this intuition of
fixed cost we'll explain.
We also, first, have to explain,
why is it the case
that the rich borrow more?
After all, it's not because
you're rich that you
necessarily have better ideas?
So to start with, should we take
it as given that the rich
should be able to borrow more?
In a sense, that's something
that's very intuitive,
because, here, too, when you
want borrow to pay for you
house, they're going to ask you
to pay at least 5% of the
value of the house.
So you can see, immediately,
that the loan you can get is a
function of how rich you are.
Or your credit is
also like that.
They ask you what is your
income, and they give you a
credit line that sort of
corresponds to your income.
But if you think for a few
minutes, in principle, where
is that coming from.
That's another thing we kind
of have to understand.
Does it come from the most basic
model, that the loan you
can get depends on
how rich you are?
It's not completely obvious.
And then once we have that, we
need to see, well, does that
help us explain that the
interest rate also varies with
how rich you are?
And that's where the
fixed costs are
going to be very helpful.
The fifth fact.
The fact that the rich
pay lower interest
rates, that's true.
And that does seem
to be linked to
how much they borrow.
The size of the loan is
inversely related to the
interest rate.
So that's kind of the same fact
as before, but it's true
more generally.
For example, in Udaipur, our
famous district in Rajasthan,
where we did all of these
studies, we also asked people
whether they borrow and
how much they pay.
And basically, the credit for
interest from a loan varied
for each hectare
that you have.
Actually, that's not a great
fact to illustrate that.
But the interest rate
is also declining in
how much you've borrowed.
So those two are kind
of related.
And the sixth fact, which we are
going to need to take into
account, is that those high
interest rates are going to be
difficult to explain,
mechanically, by default.
Because, in fact, people do
not seem to be defaulting.
Default rates are
very, very low.
So to summarize, the poor can't
borrow from formal lenders.
The interest rates are high.
The interest rates
are variable.
The rich borrow more.
People who borrow more pay
lower interest rates.
And the default rates
are very low.
AUDIENCE: Why would a rich
person borrow from an informal
lender if they could just
borrow from a bank?
PROFESSOR: Rich meaning
richer.
It doesn't necessarily
mean that they have
access to the banks.
So the name of the game--
yeah, Ben?
AUDIENCE: Aren't the rates at
the bank higher than the ones
that the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So this is
not in [INAUDIBLE].
This is in formal lending.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I mean
informal lending.
PROFESSOR: No, the rates
at the banks
are much, much lower.
If you can get a bank loan,
it's going to be at like,
nominal, in Indian, 18%
a year maximum.
And then if you could get a
microcredit loan, or you got a
microcredit loan, the rate would
be about, in India, 24%
a year, maybe, in Bangladesh,
around this.
It's much higher in Mexico.
The range charted by the
microcredit agency tends to be
outside this range, closer
to the bank rates.
AUDIENCE: For the fact the
default rates are low, could
that be that people don't borrow
if they're desperate?
Could that also be because
they won't get a loan if
they're desperate?
Because they don't have enough
capital, people won't trust
them enough to loan to them
in the first place.
PROFESSOR: So the default
rates are low.
And people who borrow are often
people who borrow for
productive investments,
et cetera.
I think you're exactly right,
that people will try not to
lend to someone who has a very
urgent need and might not be
able to reimburse.
So the fact of that the default
rates are low is an
equilibrium outcome.
It's the result of how the
lender decides to lend his
money and how much
monitoring they
are exercising, obviously.
AUDIENCE: So it would also make
sense to give more loans
to the rich, because it's not
very profitable, the very
small loans, if you're going to
get a very small interest
rate over it at the time.
And like the money basically
costs you, as a lender, to
give up that remaining 10th of
a loan to someone, especially
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is intuition coming
back to the fixed cost.
If the cost of money, for the
moneylender, is proportional,
he's also paying some interest
rate to a depositor, people
who are giving money to him.
Or maybe he is getting money
from a bigger moneylender.
And so that proportional to
how much he is getting.
So the cost of fund, itself,
is proportional.
So the cost of fund would not
explain why a small loan is
more expensive than
a big loan.
So we have to add something to
that, which is something about
the cost of administering
the loan.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that's exactly
where we're heading.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What about default
rates for the poor when
they're borrowing
from informal?
PROFESSOR: This is that.
This is what it is.
The default rate for the poor,
when they're borrowing from
informal sources is very low.
The default rate, from anyone,
when they're borrowing from
the bank, is very high.
But that is because the bank
is largely not a lending
operation anymore.
AUDIENCE: Is the reason the
interest rates are different
in different countries because
the fixed cost environment
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It might well be.
And I want to go back to that.
So let's write down some models
that formalize a little
bit the intuitions that
have already come.
So let's start with the
simplest model.
So the name of the game is going
to take these facts and
write down a model.
The simplest model, with the
fewest assumptions possible,
is going to help us make
sense of the facts.
So let's start with your
14.01 type of model,
like a basic model.
What should the model be?
Suppose that you have d% risk
of default on any loan, but
that's do the fact
that someone's
business has collapsed.
It's not that they ran away with
the money or whatever.
It's just something happened.
There business collapsed.
They can't reimburse.
So that's d%.
That is observable
by everyone.
And let's assume that the growth
interest rate is big R,
so that's 1 plus little r.
And suppose that banking
or moneylending is
a competitive industry.
And so the moneylenders
make no profit.
We're going to return to that,
whether it's a good assumption
or a bad assumption.
But suppose, for the moment,
that lending is
a competitive industry.
So we are going to use
a 0 profit condition.
So the expected marginal product
of capital has to be 1
minus d times R, So the
depositors, whatever you need
to set to big R, such that
you're depositor are getting 1
minus d times R.
So this d is very high.
Then you need to set a higher
interest rate, so that you can
compensate your depositors.
So that would be your
basic model.
Now, let's look at what kind of
facts can it explain, what
kind of fact can
it not explain.
So we go back to the fact.
Does it have anything to tell
us about formal versus
informal lenders?
In this model, everything
is seen, observable.
So, in principle, everybody
should be able to lend to the
poor, formal or informal.
But this model doesn't tell us
why the banks are not able to
lend to the poor.
Can it explain high
interest rates?
And under what conditions
would it explain
high interest rates?
AUDIENCE: If under the
assumption that the poor
default more often than the
rich, then it would make sense
to charge them a higher
interest rate
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
If the default rate was very
high, you would explain the
high interest rates.
And if they were differently
high for the poor than for the
rich, you would also explain
that the interest rate paid by
the rich is higher
than the poor.
So the problem is that you can't
both explain the high
interest rates and the
low default rate.
Given the low default rate,
you should have
low interest rates.
Likewise, given the low and
reasonably similar default
rate, there is no reason
for the interest
rate to be very variable.
The interest rate paid by
everyone should be the same.
And there is no reason
for the rich to be
able to borrow more.
You should be able to borrow
what you need to borrow, as
long as you're willing
to reimburse.
And you should also not be
a lower interest rate.
So that's kind or a long winded
answer to your question.
Even if the cost of fund is--
maybe the poor want less money
because they have smaller
projects.
But in that case, if the only
problem is the cost of fund
multiplied by some chance of
default, then that really
shouldn't fit the facts.
So we need to introduce
something else to make sense
of this fact.
So I'm going to do
it in two steps.
First, I'm going to introduce
the possibility that the
borrower might want to run
away with the money.
So they have invested in their
little enterprise.
Their enterprise succeeded.
But still they managed to
escape with the money.
So imagine that the bank or the
moneylender lends to an
entrepreneur who has a business,
which will lead the
F of k, when k units of
capital are invested.
So you invest k and
you get F of k.
So supposing you have a little
shop, and you build some
shelves, and you start
your business, and
you'll get F of k.
So if you already have w, in
order to invest k, you need to
borrow k minus w, right?
And then at the end of the
period, you need to reimburse
k minus w, multiplied by the
growth interest rate, what
you've borrowed plus
the interest rate
on what you've borrowed.
Everyone's on board with that?
So if we didn't have the chance
that people run away
with the money, we
would be done.
Now, suppose that you could
spend some cost, h, and then
you could run away
with the money.
And suppose that spending the
cost, h, is not on the amount
of money you've borrowed, but on
the entire amount of money
you've invested.
So basically, in order to run
away with the money, you need
to dismantle the shop and then
take it, move away somewhere.
So you need to try to move the
capital, so that's on the
entire shop you need
to pay the cost.
And that's some cost, h.
And then suppose that you need
to pay some money to your
depositors.
So the cost of capital is
D, low cost of capital.
So if you're the moneylender,
if he gets 1 in capital, he
needs to repay D times 1
at the end of the day.
So let's look at the
borrower choice.
And the end, when he's realized
his money, he has a
choice between repaying.
So if he repays, he will get F
of k, which is what he's made
with his business, minus K minus
w, what he has borrowed,
multiplied by the interest rate,
growth interest rate.
So that's if he decides
to behave.
If he decides to run away, he
still gets F of k minus the
cost of running away.
Now what is the lender
going to do?
At the end of the day, this
is the choice that
the borrower has.
What's the lender going to do?
Ben?
AUDIENCE: Make R times
k minus w term
smaller than the hk term.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
He's going to try to make
it worthwhile for
the borrower to reimburse.
So it's going to set R times k
minus w lower than hk, or at
least equal.
That is in order to make it
worth the while for the
borrower to reimburse.
So suppose we equalize that.
We make R times k minus
w equal to h of k.
That gives us the expression
that's over here, which is k
over w is R times R minus h.
It looks like it's almost
like a movie.
Occasionally, some very, very
noisy guys passing back.
At any rate, so can you discuss,
interpret, a little
bit, this graph,
this equation?
What is it telling us?
What is it telling us that
is possibly interesting?
A lot of it's already here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You would assume that
then interest rates would
be lower, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They could play with
R. But remember, they
have the depositors
on the other end.
So they don't have much of a
choice for R. So what are they
going to try?
What's the variable of
adjustment for the lender?
AUDIENCE: The loan size.
PROFESSOR: It's the loan size.
So what are they going to
do if you're poorer?
AUDIENCE: They'll make the
loan size smaller.
PROFESSOR: They'll make
the loan size smaller.
So R is not really a variable
with which they can play much,
because they have to pay the
depositor on the other end.
So they have to make 0 profit,
otherwise they'll lose money.
So what they are going to play
with instead is they are going
to play with the amount
of money that is
being lent to people.
So what this is going to deliver
for you is that you
can't borrow as much
as you want.
You're going to be able to
borrow some multiplier of how
much money you already have.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't they also
play with the cost of leaving,
like increasing the cost.
PROFESSOR: Right, they could
also play with h, exactly.
So what does that tell us?
For example, how could they play
with the cost of leaving?
AUDIENCE: Regulations,
bankruptcy law.
PROFESSOR: They could play
with bankruptcy law.
And if they're an informal
moneylender?
So if they're informal, in a
village, so they don't really
have the option of using
the police or whatever,
what could they do?
AUDIENCE: Well, if they're all
part of the same village,
everyone knows one another,
just use the social ties.
PROFESSOR: They could
use social ties.
What else could they do?
AUDIENCE: They could
beat the person.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: If the person feels
like there will be some
physical punishment.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they could
break people's kneecaps.
Or at least they could credibly
threaten to make
people offers that they won't
be able to refuse.
Lisa?
AUDIENCE: Which is probably why
in some contexts, or at
least some historical contexts,
like the mafia and
organized crime.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
This is why the mafia is very
well placed to lend to you,
because they can very credibly
commit to go and torture your
sister and your first born if
you don't send back the money.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Before, we were talking about
why the poor don't tend to
default on their loans, which
made the first probably not
really [INAUDIBLE].
But why were there high
default rates for the
government loans?
PROFESSOR: We can try and
interpret that in context of
this model.
Can the government threaten to
go break your kneecaps if you
don't repay?
No.
Well, not very effectively.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I said in
Libya they can.
PROFESSOR: In Libya they can.
I don't know what's the default
rate on Libyan loans,
actually, now that
you mention it.
AUDIENCE: I bet it's
a lot higher now.
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
But they're credibility of
whether they can threaten
breaking the kneecaps of people
has certainly gone
down, since their own kneecaps
are in trouble at the moment.
But that would be one thing.
And another thing, going back
to Svetlana's point, is that
the bank also knows
people less well.
So it's kind of much easier to
run away with the money of the
bank, when the bank
officer sits a
little bit farther away.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Why don't they just
keep stuff as security?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So they can also.
This is like a way of making
things costly is you keep some
amount of money yourself.
You keep some amount of
the money yourself.
So it could, here, be that part
of the cost, hk, is that
part of the capital invested,
in fact--
this wasn't in the model,
but we could include it.
If you are going to invest that
much in your company, you
need to give me a bit on the
side, which I'm going to keep
as a collector for the loan.
So that's a pretty good model.
It explains a number
of things.
It explains, in particular, that
the rich can borrow more.
We're taking the fact that
the default is low.
The default rate is low not
because people are very nice,
not because of the kind,
fundamental nature of the
poor, but because things that
set such that they won't go,
they won't default.
It's an equilibrium outcome.
So the rich borrow more.
The poor and the rich-- that
should be green-- that the
formal lender at
a disadvantage.
What we don't really get from
this model is the facts on the
interest rates.
Here, the interest rate is
being pinned down by the
default rate.
And it has nothing to
do with how much you
borrow in that model.
So it is neither different for
the poor or for the rich nor
is it higher when you borrow
less nor should it be very
variable nor should it be
particularly high, actually.
The only thing that this model
delivers, which is already a
first thing, is this rationing,
that some people
won't be able to go as much
as they would want to.
Another thing is that this also
does not deliver another
fact, that some people might
be unable to borrow at all.
Here, everybody can borrow
just some fraction
of what they have.
So if you have very
little, you can
borrow very small amounts.
And if you have a lot, you
can borrow a larger loan.
But everybody has some access.
So that model is missing
something.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In this model, if
you're a poor person, isn't
your w lower, so, therfore,
your R would be different?
PROFESSOR: No.
The w is lower, therefore, the
k will be lower, but the R
will be the same.
Because in this model, the R
is entirely pinned down by
what you have to pay
the depositor.
So in this model, it's not
going to be any default.
And the only thing that is going
to vary across people is
the loan size.
So we need to introduce one more
thing, which you already
mentioned, which is the
idea of a fixed fee.
We need to introduce that
there is a fixed fee to
administer the loan.
So you already have all
mentioned it as something
rather obvious, so maybe I need
to not spend much time to
explain why there would
be a fixed fee.
So even a small loan requires
some effort.
So you need to open a
line on your Excel
document for this person.
But more importantly,
you need to go
and do some due diligence.
So Aleem describes how the
moneylenders spend like a
number of days to--
I wanted to check the X,
which is it's an X.
But you need to spend like two
or three days, kind of go and
visit the person, figure out
who they are, who their
siblings are, so that you can
go break their kneecaps, and
what their business is, and
whether they are really
intending to do the business,
and then some kind of regular
checking of what's going on.
That's money, time,
and time is money.
So anything you want to do,
it's going to cost you a
little bit of money.
So it seems kind of.
[INAUDIBLE], you already
made this point.
So it's not very
controversial.
But that's going to
play a big role.
We already went through
the intuition.
Intuitively, now you have a
fixed cost that you also need
to recover on the loan.
So the interest rate is going
to need to adjust to recover
that fixed cost.
So that's the intuition.
What I want to show you now is
that the interest is going to
more than adjust one for one.
It's going to adjust
many for one.
So a small fixed cost is going
to lead to a big explosion in
interest rates.
And let's see how that works.
So we're going to assume that
it's the same thing.
You can run away with the money,
by paying some cost.
So you can run away.
So it says, before, you can
decide by running away.
You can decide to run away.
That's the second
equation here.
You could decide to run
away at the end.
So we are going to need to set
how much you can borrow to
make sure that you don't
want to run away.
But in addition, you have
to pay some fixed costs,
otherwise, if I give you the
money without paying the fixed
cost, you can run
away at cost 0.
So you have to pay some fixed
cost on the loan, anyway.
So now, the lender must satisfy
two constraints when
he picks both the interest rate
and the amount he lends.
Number one, he needs to still
satisfy the previous
constraint, which is the amount
lent must not be too
high to give people the
temptation to run
away with the money.
Number two, the amount of
interest that he's collecting,
when he collects, must be
sufficient to cover what he
needs to pay the depositor,
which is D, that's the growth
interest rate paid
to the depositor,
plus the fixed cost.
That is the new term, relative
to what we had before.
You OK with these
two equations?
So we need to manage
these two things.
Now we're going to combine
these two equations.
And when we combine these two
equations, we get that hk must
be equal to D times
k minus w plus c.
That's going to help us pin down
what's the parameter here
and what's free.
What's the free variable?
D is a choice or is it given
to the moneylender?
AUDIENCE: Given.
PROFESSOR: It's given.
How about w?
AUDIENCE: It's given.
PROFESSOR: That's given.
How about c?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's the fixed cost,
so it can't really be
fixed up. h is the other cost.
That's the cost of
running away.
That's also given.
So the only free variable
here is k.
AUDIENCE: Does c not change
depending on how much money
the person [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, that's
the point.
It's a fixed cost.
So h is the part that
is very relevant.
It's the fixed cost that you
need to pay, regardless, on
the size of the loan.
So in the lending cost, there
is some cost that is fixed.
That's c.
It's like going and doing your
two days of due diligence to
know who the guy is and what
is business and stuff.
And h is the variable part.
So the only thing that we have
that is free in this
equation now is k.
So we can use it to determine
what k is going to be.
And k is going to be D times w
minus c divided by D minus h.
So what happens if dw
is smaller than c?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Then you can't borrow
if it's a negative.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, then it
would be negative.
But if it's 0, you can't
borrow anything.
So now we have a result that is
slightly different than the
one we had before.
We now have a result where some
people will not be able
to borrow at all.
Some people will not be able
to borrow at all if the
amounts that they could borrow
is too small to cover the
interest rate.
And how does k vary with w?
It's increasing.
When you're richer, you
get to borrow more.
And with h, it's also
increasing.
When you have a negative,
which is under--
if the cost of running away is
bigger, than you also get to
borrow more.
That's the kneecap argument.
k is divided by something with
a minus is front, so that
makes it negative.
So that's for the capital.
And now we can go back and look
at the interest rate.
And so we can replace the value
for k in the interest
rate expression.
And you get this expression,
which is the interest rate
that someone pays is going to
be-- you can see that people
will pay a higher interest
rate if they borrow less.
People will pay a higher
interest rate when the borrow
less, simply because the fixed
costs has to be spread over a
smaller amount of money.
And then if replace what they
can borrow in this expression,
we're getting the expression
for the interest rate as a
function of all of the exogenous
stuff in the model.
So what they are paying is the
cost, D, plus c times D minus
h divided by hw minus c.
So what you're getting is a
multiplier property, which is
when you increase the cost to a
depositor by 1, you increase
the interest rate
by more than 1.
Every time you increase the
interest rate paid to the
depositor by 1%, you increase
the interest rate
by more than 1.
And likewise, when you increase
the the fixed cost c
by 1, you increase the
interest rate paid
by more than 1.
And then the last thing you
have is the interest rate,
also, depends on your
wealth and also in
this multiplier way.
So now small differences in
the cost of funds, small
differences in the cost of
monitoring the loans, either
the fixed costs or the variable
costs, or small
differences in wealth are all
things that are going to lead
to big differences in
interest rates.
This is what we see
in the math.
But can you think of an
intuition behind this
multiplier property?
Why do we have this multiplier
property?
Why is it that it's just
not one for one?
Think of Libya.
AUDIENCE: People pay the cost
on a risk [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Risk has a cost.
PROFESSOR: That could be true.
But think in the context
of this model.
Without even exiting the model,
what is happening in
this model which tends to set up
anything that will push the
interest rate up a bit, like the
cost of fund or the amount
of you have or the cost of
monitoring or the cost of
running away?
Anything that will push the
interest rate a bit
with feed on itself.
It appears in the math, here,
very clearly, but try to think
of the intuition behind this.
AUDIENCE: As interest rates
increase, there's going to be
more and more people
susceptible to
not paying it back.
So therefore, it just
perpetuates the negative
feedback cycle.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it's not so much more people,
but each person wants
to run away more.
So when the interest rate
increases, it makes you run
away more, which is necessary to
increase the interest rate
further, which makes you run
away more, et cetera, et
cetera, up to the point
where it stabilizes.
And then for some people, it
might never stabilize.
And these people will not be
able to borrow at all.
So here you won't be able to
borrow if hw is too small.
If hw is smaller than
c, you won't borrow.
The interest rate would
be infinite.
Because that spiral will
not stabilize.
For other people, it just
feeds on itself.
So now this model can explain,
pretty much, all of our facts.
The poor can't borrow from the
formal lenders, while some
people won't be able
to borrow at all.
And in particular, people will
be not very able to borrow
from places which are not able
to impose high costs.
They are just going to not be
able to borrow to the poor if
they want to get
the money back.
The interest rates are high.
That's because if the cost of
fund is D, the interest rate
multiplier relative to
that, so you can
have a big wedge now.
It's not only the
default rate.
It's like all this effort that
you have to pay to get people
to reimburse.
The interest rates are
very variable.
And, in part, because, for
example, you know someone a
little better.
So that goes back to the
question that was before about
favoritism.
Maybe it's favoritism.
You know them better.
Well, here, if you know someone
better, you can indeed
lend them at lower rates,
because knowing someone
better, maybe, reduces the fixed
cost, c, or maybe it
increases the cost
of running away.
All of this will have big
effect, big jump on the
interest rate.
So you could have very large
variation in the interest rate
as a function of this
h and c, et cetera,
within the same village.
So that's the interests
are variable.
The rich can borrow more.
That's because what you can
borrow is a function of how
much wealth you have.
And the rich pay lower interest
rates, because they
borrow more.
That's because of
the fixed costs.
And that's good to a point.
And that's all in equilibrium.
In this model, there are no
defaults, since everything is
set up to ensure there
is no defaults.
So the default rates are
nothing but automatic.
They are the result of
people setting the
interest rate that way.
So I think, at an intuition
level, you had seen where this
was coming.
But you can see that introducing
these fixed costs,
plus this proportional cost of
running away helps us kind of
cover, pretty much, all
of our bases in terms
of the basic facts.
And then we can go a little bit
further, and we can start
thinking about other things that
we might try to explain
with this model.
So moneylenders are close
to the people.
So they are the ones who
area able to borrow.
They are the ones who are
able to punish people.
They are the ones for which
the fixed cost is lower.
They may be able
to impose large
penalties, like the mafia.
An example we have in the book
is, in India, people called
Kabuliwala are the moneylenders
or were the
moneylenders of choice.
I don't know if they
are still there.
Kabuliwala, the men from Kabul,
who had this reputation
of being very fierce.
So every like Indian child read
the story about the man
from Kabul, with his tender
heart, but who ends up killing
someone, because that person
has treated them badly.
And so you would see a villager
telling this story.
Or you would see these guys
coming under the pretense of
selling you dried fruits and,
in fact, being moneylenders.
Because they are the ones who
you knew that they would be
able to get at you, with a very
persuasive argument, if
you were not going to
be able to lend.
AUDIENCE: I've only read the
article so far, so this might
be in the book, and I
don't know this yet.
I was a little curious about
why the banks never work
directly with these people?
Is it like a liability thing?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there's an example of that
where Citibank, in India,
decided that, why wouldn't
they use these guys.
So they tried to use the kind
of local thugs to repossess
their car loans.
But once it got found
out, like they
ran into big trouble.
And they had to stop
that operation.
And it's not clear whether or
not it's welfare increasing to
forbid Citibank to use
the goondas to
recover their car loans.
But they tried.
And then they ran into problems
with the law.
So it turns out that it's not
legal to kill people who don't
reimburse your loan.
So that was the problem,
exactly.
That's a good point.
There is another anecdote in the
book about formal banks--
I don't remember if
it was Citibank--
threatening to send
people eunuchs.
Because, in India, eunuchs
showing their private parts is
supposed to be like
a bad omen.
So the thing is, pay up,
or we'll send the
eunuch to see you.
AUDIENCE: Did you say, eunuch?
PROFESSOR: I don't know how--
eunuchs.
AUDIENCE: You know, eunuch.
PROFESSOR: Eunuch, eunuchs.
AUDIENCE: So it's just like
their presence is considered
like threat in itself?
PROFESSOR: Their exposition.
If they expose their
private parts, it's
supposed to be bad.
AUDIENCE: Seriously, the banks
were hiring people to flash
themselves?
PROFESSOR: Not people,
eunuchs.
I mean, people who
are eunuchs!
Not just anybody.
Not anyone.
It's a very specialized
industry.
So that explains why the
moneylenders have a good business.
Basically, it's a bit like,
you have to resort to very
complicated stuff.
If you're a bank, you
can't threaten to
kill people, et cetera.
So the moneylenders
are well placed.
The problem, however, is that
moneylenders don't have,
themselves, access to
very cheap funds.
Because if you have savings,
maybe giving them to a
moneylender is not the best
thing you can do.
So moneylenders, themselves,
they're cost of fund is high.
And there is also a multiplier
on the cost of funds, which
explains why the interest
rates are high.
So you'd explain why you have a
moneylender doing a good job
and why their interest
rates are so high.
So it is not entirely clear,
when you're talking about
driving them away, that they
are necessarily bad people
trying to exploit the poor.
They also have their own cost of
funds that it is expensive.
And then they are trying to
make a living in this way.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Well, if formal
institutions can't work
directly with the poor borrowers
and enter that
interaction, why can't they work
with the moneylenders,
since those would borrow
larger sums?
And they could be like a private
person who would just
decides to borrow from someone
and later decides to do
something with it.
Why can't that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I think, in a lot
of cases, it's sort of
happening, which is the
moneylender is like a big
landlord, who will take
a loan from the bank.
So I think part of the money
that the moneylender is
getting is precisely coming
from the bank.
So that intermediation exists.
Maybe not be officially,
because moneylending
is often not legal.
But they just go and they
borrow some money.
And then they relend it.
And that's it.
AUDIENCE: How do these rates
change with the objective of
the lending institutions and
the objective of the people
who are receiving the loans?
So if there was a social
purpose, as opposed to a
for-profit purpose, then the
spread would be smaller.
You'd be trying to break even
versus trying to make some
income off of the person
you're lending to.
And I also imagine, if you're
lending to someone who is just
trying to smooth their
consumption, they'd be more
likely to pay you back then if
you were lending to someone
who was trying to start a
business then, who's success
rate might also be low.
PROFESSOR: So in this particular
model, we have
assumed-- and, in fact,
I'm going to come back
to that in a moment--
that there is perfect
competition between
moneylenders.
So people, are here,
breaking even.
So in that sense, you can't do
better from that without
starting to lose money.
However, you're exactly right
that someone could decide that
it is worthwhile for them
subsidize the interest rate.
For example, you are
like an NGO.
And you want to do something
good for the poor.
You could decide that you're
going to want to subsidize the
interest rate, a bit.
And then you're going to benefit
from the multiplier
rate the other way.
So if you were good at it, if
someone had the local presence
and were able to replicate
what the moneylenders are
doing, in terms of lowering the
rate of running away with
the money and lowering the fixed
cost of lending, and
they combined that with some
subsidies of the interest
rate, then the multiplier would
play in your favor.
And that's where the microcredit
comes in.
When we talk about microcredit,
in a way, they
are still, say, trying
to break even.
Or they might even be willing to
lose a little bit of money.
And this losing a little bit of
money might translate into
a large drop in the
interest rate.
You're exactly right.
If you're willing to, any profit
that you're going to
give away might translate into a
lot of money saved, from the
point of view of the lender.
You're also right on the other
end, which is all of these
things depend on the propensity
of people to run
away and things like that.
If you could identify good
borrowers that are not going
to default, they are borrowers
with a big h, in a sense.
And there are borrowers
you could lend to
with a lower rate.
The problem is, for the
moneylender or for the bank,
is whether they can identify
people with a low
or high h or not.
In this world, you would
have what you see with
moneylenders, which is
moneylenders that charge very
high rates, get very low
defaults, in equilibrium, they
don't need to break anybody's
kneecap, as long as it's known
that that's what would happen.
Another story about the
moneylenders, however, is that
it is not that they just have to
charge this high rates and
variable rates because of the
fixed cost of lending and
monitoring the loans,
but because they
are monopoly lenders.
So that's another thing that you
often hear is that these
guys, it's one game in
town in the village.
They are the only one who can
lend the money to you.
And therefore, they are just
charging you this huge rate,
just because they are the
only possibility.
And you have two facts
when trying to
evaluate these claims.
You have two facts which are
pulling in slightly different
directions.
One fact is that, usually, in a
village, you have more than
one moneylender.
You could have at least like
four or five moneylenders,
which are like the shopkeeper
and then the guy
who has a big land.
And two or three people like
that will be moneylenders.
So in principle, there is
competition between them.
However, you don't see
people switching.
So people usually stick
to the same person.
So it is not clear in the end.
Is it a competitive situation,
because, in principle, you
have a choice?
Or is it a monopoly situation,
because, in practice, you
don't switch?
So what's your view of how we
can try and explain that, by
just enriching this
model just a bit?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm not sure how
to incorporate this, but I
can think of two facts.
First, the person who borrows
needs to have some trust for
the moneylender, in the sense
of like the moneylender says
you have to pay this interest
rate and then doesn't raise it
immediately when you actually
go to repay.
And that requires some costs
to establish this
relationship.
Then there's also some cost to
switching, again, to establish
this relationship with
another moneylender.
But there might be the trade-off
that you hear, from
other people, that the other
moneylender charges
significantly lower rates
or something like that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if evaluate on the cost
of switching-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Didn't you also say
that the c would decrease if
you stayed with the
same moneylender?
Because they don't need
to recheck you out.
So in the future, they can
charge you the lower rate
because of this.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So there could be.
You see, this cost of switching,
part of it is the
guy trying to figure
out who you are.
So we can think a part of
the c as being paid
once and for all.
And then maybe you're paying c
again every time you borrow.
But a part of the c might be,
maybe, paid once and for all.
Now, it means that, if you want
to switch, you would need
pay this c again.
So number one, that would mean
that you would pay a higher
interest rate.
Number two, on the other hand,
the lender, to whom you are
coming, he's going to wonder
about, why is it
that they are switching?
If the c has been paid, once and
for all, you should want
to stay with your moneylender.
If you're not, it might mean
that you have something
suspicious about you.
So here, in this model, we have
only included a moral
hazard that is the probability
of running
away with the money.
But there could be an element
of adverse selection.
There could be some people who
are more likely to run away or
less likely to run away.
And you just don't
know as a lender.
And you need to investigate.
Now, if you're trying to
switch from an existing
lender, lending relationship,
which, in principle, gives you
these lower rates, it might be
because you have something to
hide about what your cost is.
So the resenting moneylender is
going to think that you are
a high risk kind of a guy.
So he's either going to spend
even more effort checking you
out, or he's going to charge you
higher rate and lend you
less money to correspond to
the most risky people.
So because of that, the fact
that you are switching,
because it might signal that
you're a bad type, makes it
even less likely that
you'll switch.
So if we add a layer of like
adverse selection.
You know about yourself
than the lender
knows, which is realistic.
Then that will make switching
unlikely.
That means that you're stuck in
your existing relationship,
which means that the lender will
try to exploit the fact
that you're stuck into this
existing relationship.
He will say, well, staying with
me brings you a surplus.
I'm going to extract some of
that surplus from you, which
means that, even though there
is a lot of competition,
ex-ante, ex-post, you might
be stuck in a one on one
exploitative relationship.
So that's why we can have
these kind of two things
together, of a lot of
competition and, at the same
time, this one on one monopoly
relationship.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For all this to hold
true, it must be true that
rates that the different
moneylenders
charge are about equal.
Because if there was a huge
benefit to switching, it might
out weigh the costs.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's to a point, it's
going to equilibriate.
So basically, what the
moneylender that your are with
is going to do is that they are
going to set the interest
rate just low enough that
switching is not worth it.
But that means they are going
to start making a profit on
the people in which they
have a relationship.
Because now, they know that they
can do better than just
charging the break even rate.
Because there is this gain of
thing with them, which is a
very big gain.
Because the other people would
be quite suspicious of you.
And you're exactly right.
Everybody will end up charging
the same rates in a village,
in equilibrium.
And this rate will be higher
than the rate that they would
have been charging in
the absence of this
difficulty to switch.
So that's why you could have
like this combination of, you
know, they are kind of running
their business in a difficult
situation, and they are actually
taking advantage of
their clients.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I know that one of
the articles that I read--
I think it was [INAUDIBLE]
professor that proposed it or
proposed-- or maybe it was
the Finacial Times--
creating this central--
at least in India--
MFI, like a database of all the
loans, of some way to see
everybody's indebtedness,
across the board.
Wouldn't this help minimize
the cost of switching?
PROFESSOR: Right.
This kind of central database,
credit registry, similar to
what we have in the US,
that would help.
Because that would exactly
solve this problem.
Because then the new moneylender
would know exactly
what is your history.
The thing is the moneylenders
are not going
to enter into that.
So that is something that the
microfinance agencies could do
for themselves.
But that's something that
moneylenders won't do.
There is sort of one more fact
that is going to push the
interest rate up that is less
benevolent from the point of
view of the moneylender.
The formal institution
we already discussed.
The formal institutions
are far away.
don't have a
means to threaten people.
The formal institutions, even
if they were able to get
people to repay, they might not
like headlines of farmer's
suicide and all that.
So that doesn't put them
in a very favorable
situation to lend.
So these difficulties in the
credit market explain why,
despite the effort, the formal
institutions have been
relatively unable to lend to the
poor until now and explain
why people have access to all of
these moneylenders at these
very high rates.
The genius of microcredit is to
introduce an institutional
form that solves a lot of
these problems without
resorting to breaking
people's kneecaps.
So what microfinance does-- and
you're going to see that
in much more detail next week.
What are the key elements of
the model of microfinance?
AUDIENCE: You borrow in
groups, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And what is
the group doing?
What is the value
of the group?
See, if we put it in the context
of the model, what is
the value of the group?
AUDIENCE: So they insure
payment for each other.
So if one person defaults, the
others can cover the loan.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So where does it play out in
normal debt, in term of the
parameters?
AUDIENCE: It decreases
the run away risk.
PROFESSOR: It decreases
It could also decrease the fixed
cost, because you know
people are not running away.
The cost of the monitoring, it's
not that it decreases .
Someone still needs to pay
for the monitoring.
But it is the other people.
It's not the bank anymore.
So there is no multiplier.
The cost of the monitoring
reduces.
And therefore, because of the
multiplier effect, you can
reduce the interest rate quite
a bit as a function of that.
So that's one, group lending.
What else is microcredit
doing?
AUDIENCE: I know two of the
functions they have, like
certain payment schedules
and steps.
And typically, they assign you
some sort of consultant or
someone who helps you discuss
business plans
and stuff like that.
So your default risk is also
lower, because you'll make
smarter use of it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So they can reduce the default
rate like that.
The other thing you said is
that they have this very
regular schedule.
So they try and reduce the
administrative cost by making
all of the products the same.
So the typical microcredit loan
is you take a loan, and
then you reimburse it in 52
installments of the same size.
So that means one guy can
handle a vast number of
repayments in just one round.
They basically go from village
to village, meet with the
entire center, which is usually
a combination of these
groups, and take all the
money at once and go.
And so that reduces the c, if
you want, the cost, the fixed
cost of administering the loan,
which, again, can be
passed to the borrower.
AUDIENCE: As a result of that
as well, you're making a
relationship with
the borrower.
You build a relationship of
trust and the incentive is to
want to pay back [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, another thing
that microfinance has is
that they are lending one loan,
that's usually small at
the beginning, and then they
increase it and then they
increase it and then
they increase it.
And that's supposed to
give people incentive
to continue to repay.
Although one has to wonder
when that stops.
Because, eventually, they might
consider that they have
now built up enough that they
can just default with the
entire money.
But over the whole beginning of
relationship, you are going
to benefit from this incentive
to continue repaying.
Because now the incentive is
not only I'm going to break
your kneecap if you don't repay,
but it's I'm not going
to lend you another loan.
So making product very
standardized makes it to
available to hire people, who
are less well known, going
straight to the villages,
using the group loans.
All of that reduces the cost of
lending, which, because of
the multiplier, is passed
to interest.
And of course, they are often
nonprofit or even subsidized,
which again helps, with
regard with the
discussion we had before.
So I'm going to leave
it here for now.
And then, next time, we're going
to get much more into
detail about microcredit.